back in this country and to Washington
now where the house select committee
investigating the assault on the capitol
interviewed conservative activist
Virginia Thomas better known as Jenny
this was yesterday the committee had
waited months to ask the wife of Supreme
Court Justice Clarence Thomas about her
efforts and her encouragement to White
House officials to overturn the 2020
election results Scott McFarland is on
Capitol Hill for us he's been following
it Scott good morning this was a major
interview the committee wanted what did
she say and Tony good morning to you
Jenny Thomas was behind closed doors for
more than four hours the panel chairman
says she maintains Thomas maintains the
2020 election was stolen despite there
being no evidence of that the committee
asked for a voluntary interview to learn
more about her text messages to former
Trump Chief of Staff Mark Meadows
regarding efforts to overturn the
election results and her correspondence
with Trump aligned Attorney John Eastman
who drafted that game plan for
attempting to block the Electoral count
January 6th CBS News has obtained
Thomas's opening statement of the panel
in which she addresses whether she spoke
to her husband about her actions she
said I've never spoken with him about
any of the legal challenges to the 2020
election also saying Justice Thomas was
completely unaware of her text messages
to Mark Meadows Tony
all right Scott thank you very much
appreciate it